Houston quarterback CJ stad won a game
we thanked Jesus and NBC News didn't
seem to like that what does this moment
mean first foremost I just want to give
all glory and praise to my Lord and
Savior Jesus Christ I mean it's been
amazing what does this moment mean I
mean it's been amazing being in this
city for as short as I've been but the
love that I've got oh wait hold on I was
the supposed to be the same clip one was
how it actually went and then the other
one was how they posted it how they
edited it and post and they did you see
they cut out something kind of important
weird huh is't that weird that's
suspicious that's weird now the media
would cut out the actual heart of this
man's message which is I want to thank
my Lord and Savior Jesus Christ can't
say that it's kind of weird we're a
Christian country we're a Christian
civilization not only is that good and
true thing for him to say but it would
be very very popular